accès menant à l'ancien jardin de
familles dé fournir et qui se trouve
derrière moi ont été bouclées depuis la
matinée un important dispositif de
sécurité tiennent à l'écart journalistes
des populations locales
une bâche a été dressé pour masquer la
vue du jardin de la maison des fouilles
ont eu lieu toute la journée à l'aide
d'une tractopelle sur place des experts
scientifiques de renom le riz étaient
présents
les enquêteurs cherchent toujours à
retrouver le corps de marie angèle
domèce une jeune icaunaise handicapées
alors âgé de 19 ans disparu en 1988 et
dont michel fourniret a avoué le meurtre
ces opérations menées par la justice
dans l'yonne ont débuté mardi après deux
jours de présence le tueur en série a
regagné sa cellule étaient absents
aujourd'hui at il parlé at il donné des
indications trente ans plus tard pour
retrouver le corps de sa victime
c'est la première fois que des foules
ont lieu sur cette parcelle de jardin
pour l'heure rien n'a filtré de ces
recherches de ces opérations
mais michel fourniret devrait revenir la
semaine prochaine dans l'yonne pour
cette fois ci être confronté à son
ancienne épouse monique olivier